量子情報と計算の理解へようこそ。俺はJohn Wattrusで、IBM Quantumの
教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。これはシリーズの第11レッスンで、第3ユニットの第3レッスンにあたる。
第3ユニットは量子情報の一般的な定式化についてで、このレッスンは測定についてだ。測定は
量子情報と古典情報の間のインターフェースを表す。システムが量子状態にある間に測定が行われると、
古典情報が抽出されてその量子状態について何かが明らかになり、一般にその状態を変化させるか
破壊する。このシリーズの第1ユニットで議論された量子情報の簡略化された定式化では、通常は射影測定に
注目する。射影測定には最も単純なタイプの測定である標準基底測定も含まれる。ただし測定の概念を
一般化することも可能で、それはかなり有用であることがわかる。このレッスンでは測定を完全な一般性で扱う。
つまり、数学的な用語でどう記述されるか、量子情報の一般的な定式化にどう組み込まれるかを話す。
レッスンの終盤では、測定に関連する基本的な概念をいくつか見ていく。すなわち量子状態
識別と量子状態トモグラフィーだ。では始めよう。ここにレッスンの概要がある。
よくやるように、基本から始める。測定を数学的な用語で記述する異なるが同等のいくつかの方法も含めて。
特に測定は行列の集合で記述できる。
また、前のレッスンでほのめかしたようにチャネルとしても記述できる。部分的な
測定、つまりより大きな複合
システムの一部に対してのみ行われる測定についても議論する。次にNeymartの定理に移る。これは測定に関する基本的な事実で、
一般的な測定は常にStein spring
チャネルの表現を彷彿とさせるシンプルな方法で実装できるということだ。
簡単に言えば、一般的な測定は常に次の方法で実装できる。まず初期化された
ワークスペースシステムを導入し、次にユニタリ演算を行い、最後に標準基底
測定をワークスペースシステムに行う。これはかなり簡単に証明できて、その流れを見ていく。また
これがいわゆる非破壊測定にどう繋がるかも見ていく。最後にレッスンの
最後の部分で量子状態識別と量子状態トモグラフィーを議論する。測定の数学的な
記述から始めよう。測定は量子情報と
古典情報の間のインターフェースを提供する。システムが何らかの量子状態にある間に測定が行われると、その量子状態についての古典情報が
抽出される。加えて量子状態は一般に変化するか、場合によっては
完全に破壊される。最初はいわゆる破壊的測定に注目する。破壊的測定では
量子状態が入力され、古典情報だけが出力される。つまり測定された
システムの測定後の量子状態の仕様はない。直感的に言えば、破壊的測定は
測定されたシステムを破壊すると想像できる。だから測定後の状態は
規定されていない。これは物理的な装置が必ずしも破壊されることを文字通り意味するわけではない。これはただの数学的な
記述であり、物事をシンプルに保ち、本質的な
数学的な側面に集中するのに非常に有用だ。特に破壊的測定を記述する同等の2つの方法がある。
これはレッスンの概要で述べた。破壊的測定を記述する1つの方法は
行列の集合で、特に可能な各測定
結果に対して1つの行列がある。破壊的測定を記述する2つ目の方法はチャネルで、
入力は測定されるシステムの状態で、出力は常に対角密度行列だ。これを
可能な古典的測定結果上の確率分布の記述として
解釈できる。2つの記述は同等で、これはかなり有用だ。なぜなら与えられた状況でより便利な記述を選べるからだ。
非破壊測定についても話す。非破壊測定では古典的な測定
結果に加えて、測定されたシステムの測定後の量子状態も
規定される。非破壊測定は重要で頻繁に登場するが、ある意味では
数学的な観点から破壊的測定ほど基本的ではない。特に結果として
非破壊測定は常にチャネルと破壊的測定の合成として記述できる。
それがどう機能するかは後でレッスンで見ていく。では測定、つまり破壊的
測定が行列の集合としてどう記述されるかを見ていこう。この議論全体を通して、Xは
測定されるシステムだと仮定する。簡単のためにいくつかの仮定を置く。まず
Xの古典的状態集合はある正の整数nに対して0からn-1の整数からなるとする。そして測定の可能な
結果はある正の整数Mに対して0からM-1の整数だ。nとMの間には
何の関係も必要ない。両方とも任意の正の整数だ。もちろんこれらの集合を望むなら任意の古典的状態集合に置き換えられる。まず射影
測定がどう機能するかを思い出そう。これはシリーズの第3レッスンで最初に話したことだ。
測定結果が0からn-1の整数だと仮定しているので、射影測定は
Pi 0からPi M-1の射影の集合で記述される。これらは恒等行列に足し合わさり、これらの行列はすべてXの古典的状態に対応する行と
列を持つ。つまりこれらはすべてn×n
行列だ。xが量子状態ベクトルsで記述される量子状態にある場合、各可能な測定
結果aはPi aをベクトルsに掛けたユークリッドノルムの2乗に等しい確率で現れる。
任意のベクトルのユークリッドノルムの2乗はそのベクトルとそれ自身の内積に等しいので、
画面に表示された式が得られる。Pi aは射影なのでそれ自身に掛けても
何も変わらないという事実を使って少し簡略化できる。
最後に、巡回性を使って得られた式を少し異なる方法で書き換えられる。
再びトレースの式が画面に示されているが、なぜこのような形で式を書きたいのかが明確でないなら、
簡単に言えば、密度行列に対して射影測定がどのように機能するかを理解したいからだ
特に線形性によって、Xの状態が量子状態ベクトルsではなく密度行列ρで記述されるなら、
結果aが現れる確率は射影のトレースで与えられることがわかる
Πa掛ける密度行列ρ、これはそうでなければならない。なぜなら先に見たように、
密度行列は常に純粋状態の重み付き平均として考えることができ、対応する
確率を平均するとこの式が得られる。トレースは線形関数だからだ。だからこれが求めている式であり、
密度行列に焦点を当てるため少し整理することができる
ちなみにこれを行う主な目的は、すでに学んだことへの参照点を確立し、
射影測定のこの記述が、実はこれから見る測定のより一般的な記述の特殊ケースであることを示すためだ
では今から、密度行列に対する射影測定の動作のこの記述を
一般測定の記述に置き換えて、その関係を理解しよう。そしてここに
一般測定がある。必ずしも射影測定ではなく、半正定値
行列p0からpM-1の集合で記述され、これらは恒等行列に和する。この測定がXに対して行われると
密度行列ρで記述される状態において、各結果aはPA*
ρのトレースに等しい確率で現れる。簡単に言えば、変わったのはこれらの行列の条件を緩めたことだけで、特に行列は
射影行列である必要はなく、半正定値であるだけでよい。それに対応してΠという文字をpという文字に置き換えた
なぜならΠは射影の慣用的な名称で、一方半正定値には
pという文字を使いたいからだ。これは射影測定の記述の一般化で、ちなみに射影行列は常に半正定値
であり、実は固有値が
0と1のみである半正定値行列として代わりに定義できる。この定義が
意味をなすことは、結果確率として常に確率ベクトルが得られることから確認できる。以下の
ように。まず、結果確率と呼んでいるこれらの数値は常に非負の実数だ。それは
PAとρの両方が半正定値で、二つの半正定値
行列の積のトレースは常に非負の実数だからだ。なぜそうなのかは自分で考えてほしい
そして第二に、数値の和は1になる。トレースは線形だから
行列p0からpN-1は恒等行列に和することが要求されており、密度行列のトレースは
1に等しい。だからどの密度行列ρから始めたとしても、結果確率は確かに常に
確率ベクトルを形成する。では例をいくつか見てみよう。すでに述べたように、
射影は常に半正定値だから、射影測定は一般測定の特殊ケースだ
しかし単純なところから始めるといい。だからqubitの標準基底測定から始めよう。標準基底
qubitの測定は二つの行列p0とP1で表せる。画面に示されているように定義すると、p0はゼロのブラケットでP1はk1
ブラ1だ。これらはどちらも半正定値行列で、実際に射影であり、明らかに
恒等行列に和する。だから合わせて測定を記述する。この測定をqubitに適用すると
密度行列ρで記述される状態において、結果0が現れる確率はp0*ρのトレースだ
そして結果1の確率はP1*ρのトレースで、トレースの巡回性によって
ρの二つの対角成分が期待通りに得られる。もう一つの例を示そう。今回は
行列が射影でない。ただし半正定値で、密度行列でもある
が、それは重要ではない。重要なのは恒等行列に和するということで、だから合わせて測定を記述する
例えばこの測定がプラス状態のqubitに対して行われると何が起きるか見てみよう。
一つの状態の例として動作を確認するために。確率の計算は
画面に示されている。特に注目してほしいのは、プラス状態は純粋状態で量子状態ベクトルのket plusで表せるが、
確率を得るためにその状態の密度行列表現であるCプラスBRプラスを式に代入しなければならない
ということだ。また、破壊的測定について話しているため、
このqubitの測定後の量子状態の指定はない。だから結果
確率の指定のみがある。もう一つの最後の例を示そう。これはかなり興味深いものだ。再びこれは
単一qubitの測定で、記述するために四面体
状態として知られる四つの量子状態ベクトルを定義することから始める。四面体状態と呼ばれる理由は、ブロッホ球に
内接する正四面体の四つの頂点に対応するからだ。明確にすると、正四面体とは
各面が正三角形の四面体の立体を意味する。完全な対称性がある。全ての
辺は同じ長さで、隣接する任意の二辺の間に形成される角度も同じだ
そして今、画面に示されているように、四つの可能な結果を持つ興味深い測定を定義できる。言葉で言えば、
行列をこれらの状態の密度行列表現を2で割ったものにする。これらは確実に半正定値
行列だ。なぜなら密度行列を2で割ったものだからだ。計算を追って
実際に恒等行列に和することを確認できるが、別の見方は対称性を考えることだ。これら四つの状態を平均すると
完全混合状態が得られ、それはブロッホ球の中心にある。しかし4ではなく
2で割っているので、完全混合状態の2倍が得られ、それが恒等行列だ。この
測定についてはここで言及しないが、射影測定ではなく良い例であることを観察しておく
これはレッスンの後半で再び登場するだろう。一般測定を記述する別の方法はchannelとしてだ。これから
議論しよう。ここでのアイデアは、古典的確率状態は対角密度行列で表せるということだ。だから
測定結果は古典的なので、測定は出力が常に対角密度行列であるchannelとして考えることができる
測定結果を記述する行列だ。もう少し詳しく見ていこう。一般的な測定について
抽象的に考えると、その測定をchannel φとして記述できる。channelの入力系は
測定される系Xそのものであり、出力系は古典的な状態が
測定結果に対応する系Yだ。測定結果は正の整数Mに対して0からn-1までの整数とする。
測定結果は古典的なものだから、系Xの任意の入力密度行列ρに対して
出力φ(ρ)は対角密度行列でなければならない。例えばqubitの
標準基底測定を考え、それをchannel として記述すると、画面に示したような形で表現できる。
入力密度行列がρのとき、結果0が得られる確率は⟨0|ρ|0⟩に等しい。
結果1が得られる確率は⟨1|ρ|1⟩だ。これらの古典的な
測定結果を密度行列として表現すると、対応するchannelはこの式になる。これは
完全デフェイジングchannelに他ならない。これは完全デフェイジング
channelが極端なデコヒーレンスの形を表すという考えと一致している。デコヒーレンスはいろんな意味で使われるが、ここで言う
デコヒーレンスとは、量子状態が古典的になっていく傾向のことだ。扱っている系の周囲の環境が
ある意味で「見ている」、つまり測定しているということだ。
測定結果はchannel として記述できると説明したが、これは単なる可能性ではなく、
一般的な測定の特徴付けでもある。どういうことかというと、もちろん
出力が常に対角密度行列とは限らないため測定を表さないchannelも存在する。しかし
入力状態ρに関わらず、channelの出力が常に対角密度行列になるなら、そのchannelは必ず
画面に示した形で表現できる。ここでの測定とは
単位行列に和が等しい半正定値行列の集まりのことだ。これは複数の理由で嬉しい性質で、
行列の集まりとして測定を定義する方法に何も
欠けていないことを示している。別の言い方をすると、測定をchannel として考えるこの見方は操作的
あるいは公理的とも言えるかもしれない。測定とは量子情報を古典情報に
変換する物理的プロセスであるべきだという本質を捉えているからだ。そしてこれは最初の
純粋に代数的な測定の記述と完全に等価だとわかる。この動画では等価性の証明は扱わないが、
難しくはない。興味があれば、動画の
説明欄にリンクされているレッスンの資料で証明を確認できる。一般的な測定がある状態の系に対して行われたときに何が起きるかを議論してきた。
少なくとも破壊的測定の場合についてだ。次は部分測定、つまり
複合系の一部だけが測定される場合を話す。具体的には、系のペアXZが
密度行列ρで記述される状態にあり、単位行列に和が等しい半正定値行列の集まりで記述される測定が
系Xだけに対して行われるとしよう。当然これは
測定結果をもたらす。破壊的測定を扱っているので、測定のプロセスが系を
Xを破壊すると考えてよい。しかし系Zはまだ残っており、XをX測定することがZ
状態にどう影響するかを理解する必要がある。まず結果の
確率について話そう。系X単体の測定を扱っているので、異なる
結果の確率はXの単独の状態にのみ依存する。つまり
Xの縮約状態にのみ依存する。特に、ある結果aが得られる確率は
先と同じ公式、つまりPaとXの縮約状態のトレースで与えられる。縮約状態はRow
subxと表す。row subxはZをトレースアウトすることで得られるから、代入すると
すぐには明らかでないかもしれないが、得られる式は画面に示したように
PaをZ上の単位行列とテンソル積し、ρと掛けたトレースとして書ける。
これは確かめる価値のある等式だ。Zに何もしていないので
Z上の単位行列がこのように現れるのは直感的に理解できる。代数的にも確認できて、
それは読者への課題とする。まずρが2つの行列のテンソル積の場合を考え、次に
線形性を使ってすべてのρに対して成り立つことを示すといい。またPaが
半正定値であることやρが密度行列であることには依存しない。これはPaとρの代わりに任意の
行列を選んでも、次元が合えば成り立つ等式だ。
では測定によってZの状態がどう影響されるか見ていこう。自然なアプローチは
測定をchannel として考えることだ。測定に対応するchannelはこれで、
系Xから新しい系Yへのchannel として考えている。Yの古典的な状態は測定結果に対応する。この式では
σは系X単体の状態を表す。このchannelを
ペアXZが状態ρにある系Xに適用すると、ここに示した密度行列が得られる。
確かめるのに必要なだけ時間をかけてほしい。ここでも、まずρがテンソル
積の場合を考えて、線形性を使うことをお勧めする。最初の系が古典的で2番目の系が量子的なこのタイプの状態は
密度行列のレッスンで例として見た。各aはある確率で現れ、それは2番目のテンソル因子のトレースだから
2番目のテンソル因子を確率を掛けた密度行列と考えることができる。特定の測定結果aを得たときの
条件付きZの状態を得るには、確率で割り算する。つまり
2番目のテンソル因子を自身のトレースで割って正規化する。まとめると、ペアXZが状態ρにあるときにX
に測定を行うと、次のことが起きる。まず各結果aはPaとI、そしてρを掛けたトレースの確率で現れる。次に
ペアXZが状態ρにある間にXに測定を行うと、次のことが起きる。まず各結果aは
PaをI（単位行列）とテンソル積してρを掛けたトレースに等しい確率で現れる。次に
特定の測定結果aについて、状態Zの表現は画面に示された式で与えられる。これは今
さっき見たMatrixを正規化したものであり、そのMatrixを確率で割ることと同じだ
aが現れる確率で割るわけだ。これが意味を持つのは確率がゼロでない場合だけだと
言っておかなければならない。ゼロで割ることになってしまうからだ。でもそれは問題ない。この部分では
起こらないことを考える必要はないから。このレッスンのこのパートでは、Neymarの
定理として知られる測定に関するシンプルだが基本的な定理を扱う。一言で言えば、あらゆる測定は画面の図のように
実装できるということだ。言葉で説明すると、システムX上の一般的な測定は次のように実装できる
まず初期化されたワークスペースシステムYを導入する。その古典的な状態は可能な測定結果であり、それらは
0からn-1までの番号が付いているとする。次にユニタリ演算Uをペア
YXに対して行い、その後yに対して標準基底測定を行う。基本的にここで決まっているのは
Uの選択を除いた全てだ。そして定理が言うのは、実際にこのユニタリ
演算Uを選ぶことができて、異なる結果の確率が常に与えられた一般的な
測定と一致するということだ。ではNeymarの定理の証明を見ていこう。難しくはない。Uとして
良い選択をして、それが機能することを確認するだけだ。だがまず基本的な事実が必要だ
行列理論からの事実として、任意の半正定値行列Pに対して、常に一意の半正定値
行列QがあってQ²がPに等しくなる。一般にはPを与えるような行列は多数あり得るが
半正定値なのは常に一つだけだ。この行列を表すために使う記法はPの平方根で
言葉でもそう呼ぶ。ある半正定値行列Pについてその平方根を計算したいなら
ところで、まずPのスペクトル分解を計算してから
各固有値をその平方根に置き換えて固有ベクトルはそのままにすればいい。固有値はすべて非負なので
これは意味を成す。得られた行列が実際に半正定値であることも
Pの二乗になることもかなり簡単に確認できる。それが一意であることは別の話で、難しくはないが
行列に関する基本的な事実を使って証明できる。ただレッスンとは少し脱線するので、その部分は
所与のものとして扱う。この概念を踏まえると、
機能するユニタリ演算Uを指定するのはかなり簡単だ。画面に示されたパターンに一致する任意のユニタリ行列が実際に
機能する。最初のn列は、Xがn個の古典的な状態を持つとして、測定を記述する行列の平方根を
上から積み重ねることで得られる。残りの列は何でも
構わない。行列全体がユニタリである限り、違いはない
ところで、チャネルのKrauss表現とStein spring表現の関係との類似性に気づいているなら、それは偶然ではない
実際ここにあるのは本質的にその特殊ケースで、cross行列が全て半正定値である場合だ
確認すべきことが二つある。一つ目はこのuの選択が実際に機能するということで
二つ目は未指定の列をuをユニタリにする形で選べるということだ。では一つ目から始めよう
出発点の状態はこれだ。下のシステムYはゼロ状態に初期化され、上のシステムは
状態rowから始まる。そしてUを実行する。つまりUで共役を取る
ブロック行列で全て書き出すと画面に示されたようになる。左にU、右にUDagger、そして
中央にK zero bra zero ⊗ rowがあり、rowが
左上の隅にあって他は全てゼロという形になる。この積を少し考えると、
uの未指定のエントリは全く関係ないことが明らかだ。なぜなら常にこの
中央の行列のゼロエントリと掛け合わされているからだ。掛け算をやり通すと得られるのはこれだ
ブロック行列として示されたこの行列、あるいは直接記法を使って表すと
こうなる。これが実際には我々にとってより便利な形なので、この
式に注目しよう。便利のために、この密度行列である行列に名前を
Sigmaとつけよう。最後のステップはyに対する標準基底測定だ。yにおける縮約状態を計算しよう
持っている式からそれは簡単で、単にXをトレースアウトすればいい。これは第二のテンソル
因子に対応する。任意の結果aが現れる確率はaに対応する対角エントリだ。これを
こう書けて、PAの平方根 × row × PAの平方根
のトレースに等しくなる。トレースの巡回的性質によってPA × rowのトレースが得られる
これが望んでいたものだ。異なる結果が現れる確率は正しい。常に
出発点となった元の測定と一致する。確認すべき二つ目のことは
Uの未指定の列をユニタリになるように埋めることが可能だということだ。これは測定を記述する行列の平方根によって形成される
最初のn列が正規直交であるという事実から導かれる。これはかなり直接的に確認できる。関連する詳細はここにある
画面に示されているので、必要であれば動画を一時停止してしばらく考えてみてほしい。だが先ほど示唆したように
これは実際には前のレッスンで扱ったことの特殊ケースだ。これが
証明だ。レッスンのここまでは破壊的測定に焦点を当てていた。つまり測定された系の
測定後の量子状態についての仕様がないということだ。一方、非破壊的測定では
古典的な測定結果だけでなく、測定された系の測定後の量子状態も存在する。そして
見ていくようにNeymarの定理との自然なつながりがある。実際、非破壊的
測定を数学的に定式化する方法はいくつかあるが、Neymarの定理から直接導かれる
一つの定式化から始めよう。半正定値行列の集まりによって記述される一般的な測定、つまり破壊的な測定を考える
p 0からPN-1まで、恒等行列に和する。これをもとに
この測定の実装を考えることで、測定を非破壊測定に変換できる。Neymarの
定理の文脈で議論したように、新しいシステムyを導入し、ユニタリ演算Uを通じてXと相互作用させ、yに対して標準
基底測定を行う。そうするとシステムXはまだそこに存在していて、その
状態を考えることができる。行った分析に基づいて、特定の測定結果aを得た場合のXの測定後の状態が条件付きで
求められる。それは次のような密度行列で与えられる。
言葉で言えば、対応する測定行列の平方根で共役を取り、その後
正規化する。非破壊測定をより一般的な形で定式化する別の方法は、チャネルのクロス
行列を使ったものだ。これはNeilとTrangの有名な教科書で見つかる測定の定義だ。
例えば、m0からm m-1が次の方程式を満たす正方行列だと仮定しよう。
画面に示されている方程式は、これらの行列をチャネルを記述するクロス行列と考えられることを意味する。
実際、これらの行列はチャネルを記述するが、同時に非破壊測定も記述する。
状態rowにあるシステムが測定される際の動作は、まず結果の確率が
画面に示された方程式で与えられる。各結果はma * rowのトレースに等しい確率で現れる。
rowにma daggerを掛けたもので、結果aが現れた場合の測定された
システムの状態はこのようになる。この種の非破壊測定はNeymarの定理の場合と
似た方法で実装できる。興味があれば考えてみてほしい。
非破壊測定の概念をこれよりさらに一般化することも可能だ。例えば
いわゆる量子計測器という概念があり、これは時々非常に有用だが、この
動画では扱わない。レッスンの最後の部分では、測定に関連する2つのタスク、量子状態識別と量子状態
トモグラフィについて簡単に説明する。これらの概念についてはかなり多くのことが言えるが、ここでは本当にさわりだけを
扱う。まずこれらの用語が何を指しているか、そしてどう異なるかを明確にしよう。
最初は量子状態識別だ。ここでのアイデアは、量子の既知の集合があるということだ。
あるシステムの状態とそれらに関連付けられた確率がある。正確に言えば、
row 0からrow M-1がシステムXの可能な量子状態を表す密度行列であり、p 0から
pN-1がこれらの状態に関連付けられた確率だとしよう。確率を1つの
ベクトルにまとめると確率ベクトルになる。簡潔に言えば、量子状態のアンサンブルがあるということだ。
量子状態識別をタスクまたは問題として抽象的に考えると、
まず0からN-1の間の数が確率に従ってランダムに選ばれる。次にシステムXが
ランダムに選ばれた数に対応する状態に準備され、目標はXの測定によって
どの数が選ばれたかを特定することだ。つまり有限個の
選択肢と事前分布があり、実際にどの選択肢が起きたかを特定するのが目標だ。状態と
確率の選び方によってはこれが簡単な場合もあり、誤りなしに行うことが不可能な場合もある。
例えば誤りを犯す最小確率は何かというような具体的な問いを立てることができる。
また、この最小誤り確率を達成する測定はどのようなものかという問いもある。一方、量子状態トモグラフィは
異なる。ここではシステムの未知の量子状態がある。つまり
通常、事前分布も可能な選択肢に関する情報もない。ただし今回は状態の1つのコピーではなく、
多数の独立したコピーが利用可能だ。つまりある大きな数
nに対して、n個の同一のシステムX1からXnが、それぞれ独立に状態
rowに準備されている。今回の目標は、システムを測定することで、この未知の量子状態を密度行列として近似的に求めることだ。
まとめると、量子状態識別では状態の1つのコピーがあり、
有限個の既知の選択肢の中から識別しようとする。量子状態トモグラフィでは未知の量子状態の多数の独立した
コピーがあり、その状態の記述、あるいは少なくとも十分な近似を求めることが目標だ。
量子状態識別が興味深いのは、それが一般的に生じる状況を抽象化しているからだ。
例えば計算や暗号では、有限個の可能性の中からどれか1つが実現し、誰かがそれを
量子システムを測定することで特定しようとする。最も単純な非自明なケースは
選択肢がちょうど2つ、つまりmが2に等しい場合だ。タスクは1対の
状態を識別することだ。このケースは、目標が誤識別の確率を最小化することだとすれば、本質的に完全に解決された問題だ。
測定に対して最適な選択があり、それはしばしば
Hellstrom測定と呼ばれる。実際に射影測定であり、次のように記述できる。
まず2つの選択肢の重み付き差、つまりp 0 * row 0マイナスP1 * row 1を考える。
これらの2つの状態のそれぞれを引く確率を状態自体に掛け、
差を取っている。それはエルミート行列だ。なぜならそれ自身の共役転置に等しいからで、スペクトル
分解を持つ。特に固有値がすべて実数であることがわかる。では
画面に示された形でスペクトル分解が書かれているとしよう。次にすることは
固有値を2つの集合に分けることだ。正の固有値は一方の集合に、負の固有値は
もう一方に入る。正確に言えば、s0を対応する固有値ラムダKが
非負であるすべてのインデックスkの集合とし、S1を残りのインデックス、つまり負の固有値に対応するものとしよう。
実際にはゼロの固有値に対応するインデックスがどちらの集合に含まれるかは問題ではない。
ここでは任意にゼロをs0に含める選択をしているが、それらの一部またはすべてがS1に含まれても何も変わらない。重要なのは
正と負の固有値を分けることだ。最後に2つの射影Pi
0とPi 1を画面に示されているように定義する。言葉で言えば、Pi 0は
非負の固有値に対応する固有ベクトルが張る部分空間への射影で、Pi 1は負の固有値に対応する固有ベクトルが展開する空間への射影だ
これらは確かに射影であり、
それらを足し合わせると単位行列になる。なぜなら固有ベクトル S 0からS N マイナス 1が
正規直交基底を成すからだ。この測定が今の状況、つまり
測定される状態が確率 p 0 でρ 0、確率 P1 でρ 1 である場合に行われると、
正しく識別できる確率が、固有値 Lambda 0 からLambda n マイナス
1 に関してかなり単純な式で表せることがわかる。このビデオでは計算の詳細には立ち入らない。興味があれば動画の説明欄にリンクされている文書を参照するか、
この式が実際に正しいかどうか自分で確かめてみてほしい。これはまた
トレースノルムと呼ばれる行列ノルムを使っても表せる。これはベクトルのユークリッドノルムと似た表記だ。
ただし添字に 1 を付けてトレースノルムであることを示す。トレースノルムは非常に重要で、
Quantum Computing において非常によく登場するが、このレッスンではそれ以上は述べない。
エルミート行列に対するひとつの定義は、固有値の絶対値の和であり、
この第二の等式はその定義から直接導かれると考えることができる。トレースノルムはまた
より一般的な別の方法でも定義でき、次のレッスンでもトレースノルムに再び出会うだろう。実は
これが達成できる最善だ。この測定は最適であり、正しい
推測の確率を最大化することを目標とする場合に限る。その事実はHelstrom-Holevo定理と呼ばれることがあり、単にHelstromの
定理と呼ばれることもある。つまり正答確率という点でこの測定を超えることはできず、
測定そのものに対する単純なレシピと、トレース
ノルムに関する正答確率の厳密な式があるのがうれしい点だ。トレースノルムは密度行列間の観測可能な差異を測る手段としてよく使われる。
まさにこの理由から、人々が状態間のトレース距離と言うとき、通常は
二つの密度行列の差のトレースノルムの 1/2 倍を指す。ここでこれは p 0 と P1 がともに 1/2 の場合に対応し、
それは自然に考えるべきケースだ。二状態の量子状態識別は
Helstrom測定によって最適に解かれる。そこには単純なレシピと正答
確率の単純な式がある。では三つ以上の状態を識別したいときはどうなるのか？この場合、
最適な測定の選び方に関する一般的な式も、最大正答確率の単純な表現も
一般にはない。ただしコンピュータの助けを借りて最適測定の良い近似を求めることは可能だ。
特に半正定値計画法と呼ばれる実に魅力的で強力な最適化手法を使ってそれができるが、
例えば鉛筆と紙で実現することは現実的ではない。一方、もし誰かが
ある測定の記述を提示して、それが量子状態識別タスクに対して最適だと主張するなら、
その主張を検証または反証することは実は非常に簡単で、いわゆるHolevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax条件を使ってできる。このビデオでは何であるかは説明しないが、それらは単純な条件であり、
これが可能であることはかなりクールだ。ここで四面体状態に話を戻す例を挙げよう。
これはこのレッスンで先ほど見たものだ。これら四つの状態のうちの一つが、それぞれ
確率 1/4 で無作為に与えられるとしよう。目標はどの状態が与えられたかを判定することだ。おそらく驚くことではないが、
この目的の測定として最善の選択は四面体測定だ。任意の純粋状態の集まりに対して常に
このようにできるわけではないが、ここには対称性があるためこれは
うまく機能し、有効な測定が得られる。先ほど述べたHolevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax条件を通じて、
これが確かに最適な測定の選択であることを証明するのは非常に簡単だ。
具体的にここで起きることは、測定が常に確率 1/2 で正しいということで、
四つの選択肢があることを考えると悪くない。正しく推測できる確率はランダム推測の二倍だ。
そしてこれらの状態に対してこれが最善である。次に量子状態トモグラフィーについてもう少し述べよう。
未知の量子状態の独立なコピーが多数あり、その状態を記述する密度行列の近似を求めることが目標だ。
実はこの問題にはいくつかの異なるバリアントがあり、仮定や
特にどのような測定を許すかによって異なる。例えば各系を個別に測定して
結果を何らかの形で組み合わせて密度行列の記述を得る方法や、すべての
系を単一の複合系として一緒に測定することも許す方法もある。後者は理論的にははるかに優れているが、技術的な観点からははるかに
要求が高い。測定の選択に加えて、
測定から得られたデータから密度行列の記述をどう再構成するかという重要な検討事項もある。
この詳細には立ち入らない。要点は単に、
量子状態トモグラフィーは単一の手順というよりも、多くの異なるバリアントを持つ包括的な概念だと示唆したいことだ。
この問題にはかなり多くの研究が行われており、比較的
最近の画期的な結果として、コピー数 n と得られる近似の精度を結びつけるものがあり、今も
興味深く活発な研究分野だ。レッスンの締めくくりとして、qubit の量子状態トモグラフィーを
見て、どのように行うかを確認しよう。ρ が単一 qubit の状態を表す密度行列で、
X1 からXn はすべて状態 ρ で独立に準備された qubit だとしよう。この
議論のため n は大きいと仮定しよう。系を
ほぼ等しい三つの山に分けて、最初の山ではプラス
マイナス基底に関する測定を行う。プラスに対応する各アウトカムにはプラス 1 のスコアを、
マイナスに対応する各アウトカムにはマイナス 1 のスコアを付ける。この測定を説明するより簡潔な方法は、
これが Pauli X 測定だということだ。なぜならプラス状態とマイナス状態は Pauli X 行列の固有ベクトルで、
対応する固有値はプラス 1 とマイナス 1 だからだ。実際これははるかによく使われる説明の仕方でもあり、
実際、スコアの期待値はシグマxとρのトレースに等しい。では、必ずしも
この期待値が何かを知る必要はないが、多くの試行で得られたスコアを平均すれば、かなりの確率で
大数の法則によって、この期待値のまあまあな近似が得られる。また、この
記述をより定量的にしたい場合に使えるよく知られた統計的境界もある。シグマyについては
系の2番目と3番目の部分で同様のことを行う。ここで変わるのは、シグマの固有ベクトルである+iと-iの状態を使う点だけだ
Yと、標準基底ベクトルが固有ベクトルであるシグマZについても同様だ
そして最後に、画面に示されている式を使うことができる。これにより係数が何であるべきかがわかる
ρをパウリ行列の線形結合として書いた場合、これらの係数の近似値を代入することで
必要に応じて少し調整して正半定値行列を確保すれば、
ρの近似が得られる。もちろん、近似の精度や
信頼度など、詳細には触れていないが、これでトモグラフィーをqubit上で実行する一つの方法の基本的なアイデアがつかめたと思う
qubitのトモグラフィーは、正四面体測定を使って行うことも可能で、実はこれが
少なくとも数学的な観点では、かなりシンプルでエレガントになる。やることは
未知の量子状態の独立したコピーすべてに対して、この一つの測定だけを行うことだ。そして
ここに示されている驚くべき式を使えば、PK *のトレースを推定することで状態の近似を求めることができる
各KについてRowを、対応する測定結果が現れる割合で求める。これもまた、
これら4つの状態間に完全な対称性があるからこそ機能する。そして実際、一般化に関連する非常に魅力的な未解決問題もある
このアプローチをより大きなシステムに拡張することについてだ。これでレッスンを終わりにする。ご視聴ありがとう
次のレッスン（精製と忠実度について）にも参加してほしい。それでは、またね